Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn is time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
February 25th,
2019 what's going on?
How?
Why?
Yeah,
I'm recording this in New York City right before I get on a plane to go fly to
London.
Um,
do my little run through a the UK tape my special and then come home and I ain't
doin shit.
Shit.
I'm taping this Sunday,
the 24th I'm tough day.
Definitely a tough day.
They have in this memorial for a Steven Brody Stevens
tonight at the comedy store and unfortunately I'm in New York and I can't be
there and I'm crushed that I can't be there and a sale.
The things I would have liked to have said,
which really is the strange thing about when somebody dies,
do you ever notice when somebody dies then you somehow,
immediately,
no emotionally exactly what you wished you have.
You would have said to the person,
it's really weird,
but I kind of get it because that's a heavy thing to do to somebody.
Like,
what would I say to this person if I knew they were going to die tomorrow?
If you just fucking hit them with that,
whether it's sitting there eating a fucking Cobb salad,
they're going to be looking at you like,
whoa dude.
Hey,
let's try to keep it light here.
Okay.
Um,
but I just,
that fucking guy,
my God,
that guy made me laugh.
Like I don't even know how to describe it.
The W and it was the way,
like nobody ever made me laugh that hard.
The way he made me laugh,
it was completely 100%.
Just a unique,
unique,
unique sense of humor.
Um,
just really,
you know what's funny is I've been,
I've been talking to all of these comics about them over the last couple of days
here and we're all like quoting his jokes and it's like,
if you don't know Brody,
it,
it's,
it's kind of like you kind of have to know him and he kind of had to be familiar
with this act to under,
cause it was his fucking cadence half the time.
Like,
um,
it's a good example.
I remember one time I was down the comedy store,
we were in the main room and I was with my wife,
Nia in Brody went on stage and I swear to God that fucking genius went on stage
and for 10 minutes to scribed his dream apartment and there was no set ups,
no punchlines.
He was just describing in like this sort of,
I can't even,
it was like Zillow speak meets like this amazing comedic cadence.
I don't even,
I can't even remember what he said.
Me and Neil would just looking at each other and were just dying laughing.
I just,
it was like,
you know,
ceiling to floor windows,
stepping down into the living room.
And when he said that wife literally almost fell out of her chair.
I know this won't seem funny to a lot of you because you didn't know him and I,
nobody can recreate what that the way that that guy did what he did.
But when he said stepping down into living room,
like I just put my head down on the table and was crying,
laughing at the same time.
Also for the first time ever in my life noticing,
um,
how much reverence,
if that's the right word,
that I held anybody.
Like any room that you stepped down in,
into,
in an apartment is unbelievably classy.
And I had no idea that I thought that.
And I think the whole crowd along with me suddenly realized in that moment that
like we all felt that and had never expressed it and Brody had just expressed it
and,
and he acted it out,
stepping down and he sort of crouched into the living room and,
uh,
it was just amazing,
you know?
And it wasn't,
and also to like,
probably behind all of that on the underneath was the sadness of,
of,
you know,
like what he wanted and was he going to get it and all of that type of stuff
that it was just very relatable.
And um,
I don't know,
man.
It's like,
I have this weird,
this is a weird one where I'm really sad selfishly for myself,
but I'm not like,
I don't know,
I'm not the most spiritual guy,
but I just,
I feel like,
you know,
his,
his journey was like complete,
I guess,
you know,
that's how I have to look at it or else it becomes too sad.
And when I really look at how we affected everybody and just the fucking
outpouring that was on,
um,
Twitter and out of sight,
he would have been that,
you know,
that he,
that he was trending on Twitter for two days now.
Um,
I dunno,
it was just,
it was really that,
that part of it was like a cool thing to see.
And I,
I used to,
I tried to sit down and watch that show that he did with,
uh,
Zach Galifianakis,
by the way,
shout out to Zach for loaning his name,
but that's so Brody could do that show.
And,
um,
it was just too soon to sit there and watch it and watch them struggle.
I just can't imagine having them,
um,
uh,
mental illness where you're,
you just literally just walking around fighting your own brain in the way that
he was able to do that and not lash out at other people and just be so kind and
so sweet to everybody and just so fucking funny,
man.
It's like,
it's really,
it's,
it's an end of an era in,
um,
at the comedy store like this,
there's really not going to be,
there's not,
there's no,
there was nobody before or after him that,
well,
that was,
that was like that guy.
And furthermore,
he truly,
in the purest sense was a,
um,
was it comic's comic where a lot of times that gets thrown around,
Oh,
this guy's a comic comic,
or she's comic's comic and it's somebody that's also selling a lot of tickets.
It's almost like,
it means it's a comedian that made it,
but other comedians still like that person
don't resent their success is sort of the way a comic's comic is sort of these,
I guess,
definition of it,
if the way I kind of see it.
But Brody was,
he was,
he was a comic's comic in that he was really for us,
like the wait staff and people that manage comics and people who had watched
that amount of comedy to understand how unique he was and how different he was.
And I loved going on the Internet now and all these people were just discovering
them.
And some people get number.
There's a lot of people being like,
this guy is,
it's funny,
this guy sucks.
Um,
I'm sure you guys are sad,
but this guy saw that makes me feel even better.
It's like,
yeah,
you don't get it.
You don't get it.
Cause you're not a fucking comedian.
And,
and,
and you just have like,
you know where your comedic IR is,
is take two guys walk into a bar and the rabbi says like,
you're not going to get this fucking guy.
Like you have to watch a lot of comedy to see,
um,
how funny this guy was.
And,
uh,
I'm,
I'm really gonna miss him in,
Oh man.
I remember when I was doing a,
I was,
what was it,
the odd ball,
the eyeball tour.
And,
uh,
I had gone on,
the crowd was fucking,
you know,
it's like,
I dunno fucking eight,
9,000 people and it was shit and it's just a such a rush to be on in front of,
in Brody was hosting and Chris Delea was going on next.
And uh,
I've always loved Chris.
Like,
he just was like,
you know,
he reminded me of like a Boston comic where as far as like,
he could get up in front of from early on,
get up in front of a big crowd and kill it.
A level that was considering headlining the way I learned what it sounds like,
what killing sounded like he was doing.
So,
um,
you know,
he was on his way out and I was saying,
I'll do you wait till you go out there,
it's going to be fucking amazing.
And I asked him,
I was like,
you want me to take a picture?
Uh,
or I don't know if I asked him what up.
So he was walking out and I wanted to take a picture of Chris right when he got
to the microphone because the lights were up.
And you could see how big the crowd was and I thought it'd be a cool thing for
him to have and retweet or whatever.
And I was just focused on Chris and Brodie had done the fucking intro and I
didn't realize he was in frame when it,
cause I was just looking at Chris to try and frame it and I,
I like the picture and I was unaware that Steven did this,
you know with his baseball background,
he has a pitcher and a,
I forget we pitched Arizona,
Arizona State,
I think it was Arizona State,
I'm not sure.
And He,
you don't,
you know that warm up that pitchers do.
Like whenever you see like spring training before the game where they're walking
and they put their hand out like straight out in front of them and like above
their head and then they just kick their leg up with their toe,
their cleat or their toe touches their hand.
I guess he used to do that.
I,
that was the first time I ever saw him do it.
And when I click the photo,
he was walking off stage doing that and he had literally kicked his foot.
Was that the apex almost touching his hand with his,
his head tucked down a little bit and I,
it just,
I saw that and I just thought it just,
it was just so him,
I just started fucking laughing and I was just as a comedian,
like why did he do that?
Was was that for the crowd?
Was that for him?
What was the person in the crowd as they're watching crystal,
Leah walking on stage and then in the peripheral they just see this guy walking
off kicking his fucking phone up to his head,
like a spring training fucking picture and the,
and the grapefruit league.
And for the rest of that fucking tour,
you know,
when you know,
you get lonely on the road,
I would just look at that picture and I would just die laughing.
And so many people that I showed who weren't in standup didn't understand why
that they would just sort of like,
wow,
that guy can kick his foot up a high or whatever.
They didn't get it or it wasn't hitting them the way it was hitting me,
but I just,
um,
I don't know man.
Uh,
I don't know what else to say.
I just,
uh,
it's,
it's just,
it's really obviously really sad,
but I just was,
I don't know the way that guy touched me by what he did.
I,
I have this weird sort of,
mmm.
I Dunno.
I can't yet,
definitely am really,
really sad,
but it's not that same kind of sadness.
Um,
and I'm not the most spiritual guy,
but if there's,
if there's anything,
he's there,
you know,
after this cause,
uh,
I dunno,
I,
I never heard anybody say one bad fucking word about that guy.
He's always such a night and he's fucking hilarious and all that.
So anyways,
there goes another one,
so.
MMM.
I Dunno,
I guess,
I don't know.
He would get frustrated.
I mean,
the whole fucking,
his whole thing is just like,
his whole life was like an Oscar winning movie.
Okay.
As far as the way he battled,
like what he battled and I'll positive he stayed.
And like,
I always wondered like what that what it was like for him to have all like the
best comics being like,
dude,
you'd like one of the funniest guys ever.
And then not getting that from the mainstream in a while,
you know,
battling all that other shit I mean and and the,
and to not turn bitter and not be a fucking asshole.
He says it's unbelievable.
It really is.
So
I now that like his life
is complete,
like kind of looking back on it,
it was like,
it was weird.
Like he was on his,
what's that grateful dead song?
It reminded me of that you know that that song ripple.
Okay.
Where they say,
uh,
what the fuck,
how does that lyric go?
Let me look this up here.
Okay.
It says there,
there's a road,
no simple highway between the dawn and the dark and night.
And if you go,
no one may follow that path is meant for your steps alone.
Yeah.
I feel like if they ever do like a documentary,
which I'm sure they're going to like,
that should be okay.
That should be the tone because I don't know,
I don't know if I'm saying this right,
but like,
yeah,
I don't know what that guy did was just so fucking unique in this.
There's a loneliness to be in that fucking unique.
And the fact,
like I said,
that he didn't turn into a fucking asshole about it and was just so nice and
supportive to everybody.
Okay.
You know,
I dunno,
I don't measure up to that.
Put it that way.
So,
okay.
Thank you to Brody Stevens and all of it.
Steven Brody,
Stevens,
all those fucking times you made me laugh and everybody else and uh,
I dunno.
I think for the rest of my life I'm going to be going.
Yes,
you got it.
It just feels good to say it.
I,
I mean,
half of my conversations I think I had with him,
sadly enough was just me imitating him.
He was so fun.
I would just start talking,
talking like him.
So anyways,
that's my 2 cents and um,
there's a bunch of clips of them.
If this made you interested,
uh,
definitely look them up and,
all right.
I guess,
I don't know.
What the fuck do you go from there?
Jesus Christ.
Dude,
look,
okay.
Uh,
this is what being oldest now.
I mean it's just fucking every black,
the comics die more than other people because I,
I,
you know,
I have a whole list of everybody that died cause I don't want to forget him and
I'm up to like fucking 32 comedians,
you know,
all guys to every single one of them.
That's how you,
for all the bitch and the women are doing standup.
At least you're still alive.
You could still do sets.
Um,
I was actually talking to de Rosa and we would just,
and we would tell him Steven Brody Stevens fucking stories.
Um,
it's the weirdest thing like on this,
cause all these people that have died,
there's always been like a sadness and blah,
blah,
blah.
And with everybody I've talked to about,
it's like you end up crying,
laughing,
telling stories rather than crying,
crying,
you know,
and we were trying to remember his,
another guy,
you should look up as far as like,
just fucking hilarious.
Who Died?
MMM.
Is it a comic?
Rasheed Thurmond,
And he died right when I went to La and I remember a young guy to like 36 37
years old.
It was another,
another great one.
So anyways,
where the fuck do you go from there?
Um,
I've been running my set here in New York City,
New York City,
one of the most caring comedy crowds.
You're going to be in front of Jesus Christ.
I sweat.
I feel like a three year comic when I perform in New York City.
Now I don't know what the fuck is going on.
Um,
part of it's me because of this,
the overly sensitive fucking horse shit that's going on.
It's forcing me to go in the other direction,
you know,
to just,
it's just,
it's the,
you know,
it's the balance of the universe.
It's like if,
if you're going to fucking
try to push me in this,
this direction,
I'm going to fucking go on the other one.
Like if you,
if you back off then I'm not going to be as much of an asshole on stage,
but if you're going to be fucking sitting there getting in my grill every time I
fucking say something,
it's good.
It makes you,
it makes you
go hopefully even further in the other direction because comics were telling me
they're going on stage out here and,
and see other comedians in front of just a regular crowd.
It's not a benefit like I get if you're doing a cancer benefit,
they go,
hey,
just don't do any cancer jokes.
I get that,
but it's just a comedy show.
And they go and don't talk about this.
Don't talk about that.
They'll talk.
Katie's fucking,
these
people are going to undo everything that Lenny Carlin and prior these guys went
to jail.
They went to jail.
So you know,
and because they did that,
believe it or not,
a lot of these female comics that are on stage now talking about their fucking
vaginas for 45 minutes,
you wouldn't be able to do that if it wasn't for them.
And now it's becoming this fucking thing where I don't,
I don't know.
I don't,
I really just am baffled and every time I think like,
okay,
well we're going to come out of this ridiculously childish time and stand up
where,
where everybody is acting like comedians of all the sudden presenting
legislation that is going to be turned into law rather than,
it's just up there.
Somebody just,
just being an idiot.
Um,
I dunno,
I was doing this
some fucking club.
I'm not going to say the club was to the club and like,
uh,
I was making fun of white women how they act like they're oppressed.
You know what I mean?
When they're really just sitting in the Jacuzzi with me,
you know,
how they get sidestep their white privilege because they weren't allowed to vote
90 years ago,
you know,
so,
um,
oh,
just got the right to vote 90 years ago,
whatever the fuck a hundred years ago.
Um,
you know,
obviously just being a dick and this white woman in the crowd just goes,
I just guys fuck.
Just like that.
Right.
And uh,
I'm like that.
That's all you got.
She's like,
what?
I had to say it like she's literally patting yourself on the back for how brave.
She was fucking hilarious.
He was just like the complete lack of passion and fire.
The way she protested what I said just,
it just really shows like how unaffected you are,
but by,
by whatever the fuck it is you're complaining about.
You know what I mean?
Truly oppressed people when they heckle.
When you say you crossed the line,
when they fucking heckle you,
you feel like,
oh fuck,
I went too far.
It isn't,
you don't sound like I was saying she sound like she was down the bottom of a
well,
hey,
so anyways,
I dunno,
I was not bringing these Steven Brody Stevens positive vibes to that show.
I was a,
I was being a bit of a Dick,
so whatever I'll take,
I always take my 50% of it,
you know?
Um,
so anyways,
I go on to London today.
Let's look up wearable freckles is going to be,
I don't even know.
I think I started Liverpool,
which I'm very excited about.
She loves you.
Yay.
Yay Liverpool.
Right.
That's where a the four fucking,
uh,
my petty concert from the Beatles.
Let's see here.
Let's go to my website,
[inaudible] dot com everybody,
if you're following along in your program,
[inaudible] dot com I'm going to be,
yes,
I'll be in Liverpool.
Oh,
would you look at that?
Not until the 26th.
So I actually get an extra day here.
I fly today.
Today's the 24th.
By the time I land will be the 25th.
That gives me a chance to fucking chill out.
I'm there for two days.
Roommate has it.
Most sal is coming to the show.
Kidding.
I really fell out following fucking soccer.
I tried,
I fucking tried.
Uh,
Jim Breuer has the funniest fucking bit about Americans trying to get into
soccer.
Go once every four years.
You'd try to get into it.
You buy the Jersey and he just starts imitating them flopping all over the
place.
But I will say this,
I do really,
really enjoy this sport now and I do see the beauty in the skill and all of that
shit now.
Like,
you know,
I'm not 100% the stupid yag making fun of the world's most popular sport and uh,
it is an all faking cause I saw mo salad a couple of times on a breakaway.
That's what they call it.
And hockey.
I don't know what the fuck they call it in uh,
in your football over there.
But like he's in the clear in this guy just runs up behind him and sticks his
leg out and dragged his clique down the back of his fucking calf.
But what was funny,
cause he was on the breakaway,
most shook it off and then kick the,
you know,
kicked it in the net.
But if he was anywhere else,
he would have collapsed on the field,
like he got shot.
Although having said all that,
I would not want somebody do that to me.
So it's not all,
uh,
it's not all faking.
So I'm in Liverpool and the 26 and the 27th,
28th,
I'm in Glasgow.
Uh,
and then the 29th I'm off.
And then the,
the first in second amen.
Birmingham and then Manchester,
legendary Manchester.
Uh,
and then where Yo,
and then I have two days off,
what the fuck?
Then I get two days off.
And then I,
um,
at Royal Albert Hall on the fourth and fifth taping my next standup special.
And,
um,
you know what I was,
uh,
watching all these clips on Steven Brody Stevens and I came across,
I went to his Instagram and all of that stuff.
And,
uh,
I was watching,
I don't know,
somehow I ended up coming across this quote that Zach Galifianakis had that I'm
really going to take to heart because I've been just working my fucking ass off.
And it was basically saying,
you know,
don't feel like you have to be,
working all the fucking time.
I don't,
I can't paraphrase,
he said it perfectly of course,
but I kind of took it to heart like,
you know,
what if I just fucking chilled out for a couple of weeks?
Um,
I got that German Irish thing where you just go until one day you fucking like,
oh,
what's that pain in my chest?
And then you just fall forward into your fucking mushy peas.
And then that's it.
MMM.
So I'm going to try to,
uh,
I want to try to be around for a few.
I mean,
I don't know how long I could do it because there is a part of me that goes
fucking nuts after four days of not doing stand up.
But,
uh,
I think I'm going to go a little bit easy here over the next couple of months in
rather than they just run out.
Because what I usually do is I immediately,
I'll take like two days off after I do a special night,
really immediately get right back to the club.
And I,
and I,
I tried to get it going again.
And,
um,
I think this time when I'm going to do is actually take a little bit of time off
from doing stand up and,
and rather than just trying to force a new hour,
I'll go live a life that sorta writes the next hour.
Hopefully.
Hopefully that'll happen now.
Watch you guys later on this year.
You know,
right after my special comes out,
I just saw him.
It's like half the same jokes that it's fucking freckled conch sucks.
Um,
all right,
so there's 23 minutes.
I don't have the advertising reads yet,
so I'm going to finish this one tomorrow when I'm overseas.
Uh,
once again,
I'm absolutely,
um,
heartbroken that's such a special person.
Like Stephen is no longer with us,
but I am like
so inspired by the life that he lived and so happy to have known him only a
little bit as this little as I know him and uh,
that I actually got to see him and
I dunno man.
It's,
I don't want,
it's the weirdest feeling I've ever had after somebody I had known that's died
where it's just like he just,
there's even a attic,
a happiness.
I have just,
I mean,
you know what it was,
I think because I just looked at his life and saw the effect that he had on
people and you know,
when he just kind of think like,
yeah,
man,
he got it.
He got it.
You know,
he
was a,
yeah,
just a,
an unbelievably positive,
positive force.
And the lesson I learned when Patrice died is that,
you know,
you don't own these people.
They're just gifts that you get.
Yeah.
And you don't get to decide when they go.
And that's sort of the,
a cruel thing that you continue to learn.
But,
um,
I don't know,
looking at his body of work,
you know,
I know personally I'm going to try to be a little bit less of a content,
try to live up to the high standard that,
that he said.
All right.
Okay.
And with that,
I'll read some advertising here from London and with the magic of editing,
this will only be a half a second delay.
Okay.
And through the magic of editing,
I am now in Liverpool,
England,
that only took half a second through the wonderful world of editing.
MMM.
Jay says Christ.
Oh God.
MMM.
So I'm in Liverpool now.
The driver was going,
you know,
you can go see where the Beatles fucking did all their first shows,
which I really think that's gotta be like the cheers of Liverpool.
Just going to walk in there.
Yep.
Right over there.
Where the,
where they're not right now.
That's where they were.
MMM.
I Dunno,
I'm just,
I don't have a show tonight,
so I'm just sitting here trying to figure out the goddamn heating system here,
which I can't figure out.
I don't know how to turn it on.
I pressed every fucking button and you know,
I brought a fucking adapter and whenever I bring them mixer,
I always blow out my fucking mixer.
And Lo and behold,
I plugged it in before I plugged it into the mixer and I just heard the,
the plug just goes like,
Eh,
no.
It was just like,
well,
I just fried that fucking thing.
Even with the fucking adapter.
I don't know how it happens.
MMM.
It didn't fry my computer,
but my computer has three prompts.
That mixer only has two.
Is that what the,
is somewhere in there?
Was it not grounded?
Was there too much of a surge?
Any electricians that can help me out?
I have no fucking idea.
Um,
but anyways,
let's continue.
Let me read a little a advertising here.
Um,
stamps.com no one really has time to go to the post office.
it sounds like a fat person making excuses.
Why they can't go to the gym.
You're busy.
Who's got time for all that traffic,
parking,
lugging all your mail and packages.
It's a real hassle,
man.
That's why you need stamps.com.
One of the most popular time saving tools for small business assistance is
stamps.com eliminates trips to the post office and saves you money with
discounts that you can't even get at the post office stamps.
Stop calm brings all the amazing services of the post office right to your
computer.
Whether you're a small office sending invoices,
Jesus Christ,
um,
on an online seller,
shipping out products or even a warehouse,
sending thousands of packages a day.
Stamps Dot Cobb can handle it all with these.
Simply use your computer.
Why is that fucking thing done with that?
Um,
please,
uh
Oh,
what am I simply use your computer.
It's simple with stamps.com you get five.
Where the fuck is simple?
Use Your computer to print us officially was postage 24 seven for any letter,
any package,
any class of mail,
any way you want to set.
Once your mail is ready,
just handed to your mail carrier or drop it in a mailbox.
It's that simple.
A stamps.com you get 5 cents off every first class stamp and up to 40% off
priority mail.
Right now,
my slash our listeners get a,
Oh,
I guess I'm supposed to say my cousin.
I'm by myself.
My listeners get a special offer that includes a four week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale without any longterm commitment.
Just go to stamps.com.
Click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and type in Burr.
That's stamps.com [inaudible].
All right,
that's it.
Um,
all right,
let's talk about some shit here.
Uh,
all right.
So I did some more sets in in New York,
had great sets Thursday night and then Friday and Saturday.
I had like those sort of typical New York sets where,
you know,
I dunno,
it's just the,
I dunno what I don't,
I don't get it.
I was up there and make it fun to women and then this woman in the crowd,
white woman of course just goes.
But yeah,
right.
So I just started making fun of her and she just goes,
what?
I had to do it,
you know,
like what she did was unbelievable and brave and all of that type of shit.
And it's just like,
you know,
I dunno if you just heard it.
It's just like these fucking white women who were acting like they're oppressed.
It's like you're white.
Okay.
That's my joke.
It's like you're in the,
in the Jacuzzi with me.
Stop this,
stop it.
This fucking whining all the fucking time.
Like,
like you're really this oppressed minority,
you know,
is this,
you could tell how a press she was by the level of passion she had when she was
yelling.
She's like,
Hey,
fuck.
You had to say like,
no passion,
no fire,
no pain,
whatever.
Oh.
And I don't only know and all it's doing,
it's just causing me to say more ignorant shit that I wouldn't be saying if,
if,
if they weren't fucking act in that way.
So,
um,
just heads.
It's just a really weird,
I don't know,
somebody actually wrote me a letter talking about the Caroline show,
which I mean I had a good time,
but by no means was it a smooth show.
Said hey old Billy,
thanks for coming out and putting on a great show at Caroline's.
You were absolutely hilarious.
I listen to your podcast and after agree with you,
the crowd wasn't typical New York.
I'm born and raised New Yorker and noticed a ton of what I'm sure were hipster
transplant.
I don't,
I think they're just younger people now.
Okay.
And I just think it's a product of being on social media and seeing everybody
getting in trouble.
Maybe that's what it is.
Because one of the Times I was doing a show in this guy was like laughing,
but he wouldn't look at me and he was almost like looking down and then looking
across it his friend like,
like he wanted to laugh,
but he was afraid too.
I don't know.
It's strange.
Then he goes,
a couple of people even kept looking over at me for laughing so much.
Just want you to know that US natives and longtime New Yorker is really
appreciated and thoroughly enjoyed your show.
I hope you weren't too put off because I look forward to seeing you perform here
again.
So,
oh yeah.
I mean I'm not going to fucking quit coming to New York.
I just,
I'm having a difficult time trying to figure out what exactly it is that I'm
doing.
I feel like a three or comic when I go to New York.
Um,
okay.
I Dunno,
but it is what it is,
you know,
it's dictated by the young,
not the old.
So they are setting the tone and I guess I have to figure out how to adjust to
it.
Um,
okay.
Oh and I'll Robert Kraft,
Robert Kraft,
getting all this shit for,
I don't know what,
you know,
the man simply was trying to buy a strip mall and he just went over there and he
was checking out some of the stores.
What is the problem?
I think it's such fucking bullshit.
That's just because he's famous.
I was talking to this cop because anytime we busted a rub and tug,
he goes,
you're trying to get the people that run it.
You don't get the Johns,
you just scare them and you let them go.
But all of a sudden he's a famous guy.
So now it's just like this big deal,
you know?
And everybody's just like,
why if you Robert Crap,
do you need to go to a rub and tug?
And I would say that's because that's how annoying it is to have a woman in your
life.
You can just get what you want without all the fucking bitch moaning and
complaining.
Um,
well I don't know why he wouldn't.
If he did.
I mean,
it's all fucking alleged anyways.
You know,
it did happen to Florida.
So,
I mean,
we've been beaten up and the dolphins for so long.
I'm sure that's why they didn't fucking let them go.
But,
uh,
it's great that it happened because it gives people,
you know,
who hate Boston because they want all these fucking championships.
MMM.
My favorite thing is when you talk about all the,
the championships that they've won,
and like,
people bring up like the eagles and the giants and it's just like,
dude,
they were six and three.
I mean,
you're not gonna win all of them.
I will take those three losses all day long to win six Superbowls.
MMM.
All fucking day long.
All Day long.
I'll take the 86 year fucking curse of the bay.
Yeah.
To come back down three games to none
and to what they've been doing.
I mean,
it's like,
it's,
yeah,
it's the pain that makes it great.
Um,
so anyways,
any way to say it properly,
let me read a few more of these as podcast might be a little bit short because
I'm beyond jetlagged and uh,
thank God I don't have a show tonight,
but now I'm like wide awake because I came here and uh,
I couldn't sleep on the plane.
I watched two movies that I really enjoyed.
I watched white boy Rick,
I got to give a shout out to that.
I mean,
Matthew mcconaughey is always great.
He's always great,
but the two people that played as kids,
a white boy,
Rick movie,
let's see here.
I just thought the acting was superb in that movie.
Really,
really good movie.
And then I also saw,
uh,
I might be able to figure it out.
There's,
I EMTB
um,
I also saw,
uh,
the,
the Freddie Mercury movie
Bohemian rhapsody.
All right,
Richie Merit fucking killed it.
And then Bel Powley,
both of them will fucking amazing.
A really good movie.
And I'm like,
well,
these are also airplane reviews.
But I still think it was,
you know,
whenever you're in an air,
Judah Friedlander used to always say that when you run a movie,
every fucking movie is good.
MMM.
But these are actually really good movies.
And then I also saw a,
yeah,
that Bohemian rhapsody,
Bohemian rhapsody.
And he always,
the funniest part of that movie for me when I saw the original reviews of
Bohemian rhapsody,
it's how I feel about that song today.
I don't know if it's just overplayed,
but that song drives me up the wall.
I see a little Sillier,
wetter,
whoever,
man,
no,
no.
They have no,
my mommy got my mum.
It's just like,
oh my God,
I get it.
You could sing Jesus Christ about a fucking through line of a thought here.
Um,
but I,
I really liked,
uh,
I liked that movie,
but,
um,
and I was,
I was in the air and missed all the,
uh,
all the Oscar stuff.
But,
you know,
I thought it was hilarious that spike Lee was upset.
It's just funny to meet when adults get mad that they don't win a fucking
trophy.
You know?
It's just like,
why?
Why do you give a shit?
Didn't you see how,
how they treated Martin Scorsese?
Yeah.
How long did he have to wait before he fucking,
before he did fucking,
if,
when he finally got best director,
when they finally gave it for him,
there wasn't,
it wasn't even his best one.
It should have been for the other ones.
It's like,
that's what's going to happen to you.
You know,
they fucked Denzel on hurricane and then give him for the,
for that fucking King Kong.
Hey God,
not that on me.
They were always like a movie.
You're too late.
You know.
I don't,
I dunno why.
I Dunno.
Why,
why would you waste your time getting that fucking,
I dunno.
Upset.
I did like that he was dressed like prince,
his grandfather though.
Um,
anyways,
anyway,
uh,
I,
and most of those other movies I didn't see,
uh,
I,
I didn't see,
so I dunno.
What,
what,
what are you going to do?
All right,
the next thing I got here,
somebody of course giving me shit for a sane.
I felt bad for Jessie Smollett.
I just felt bad as far as like,
oh my God,
he's got to feel like the biggest fucking asshole ever in this guy.
Of course gets all passionate about it because why would you get passionate
about the corporations that dictate our foreign policy and have literally
bankrupted this country when you can get mad at an actor that got 100% busted
for what he did and nobody got hurt other than him,
he totally destroyed his grades.
They can feel safe.
Bet You hope.
Who's kid?
We rebounds.
The guy who was willing to let two innocent people right in jail.
I don't think he thought they were going to get caught considering he was acting
like it was two white people.
I think what it was supposed to happen was they were supposed to sort of semi
beat him up.
He was supposed to blame it on fucking raw,
uh,
white people and like the two guys that did,
is that what you're saying?
The Guy was trying to cause even more racial division and anger in this country.
Uh,
he didn't increase it or decrease it.
It wouldn't have it just what has just been another fucking story that lasted
for three days.
It is where it is and will remain that way and took people grow the fuck up.
Uh,
the Guy Oh,
terrorized his coworkers by sending fake hate mail with mysterious white power
powder in it to his place.
Work,
Paul.
Yeah.
Head out of your ass.
Bird.
All right.
Maybe I was wrong about that.
I thought it'd be more of a unique take other than to say,
you just said what everybody else said.
Congratulations sir.
You,
no,
I still feel sorry for is you who does not have an original [inaudible].
I think what everybody else thinks,
oh,
that's entertaining.
I mean,
if I just did that,
I could just be that big headed fucking lady.
Who's that lady who does that show when she turns her head to the side?
Like Jim Rome,
you know,
she gets all mad about cases about people who you've been just horrific things
have happened to them.
But if horrific things didn't happen to them,
then she wouldn't have a mansion.
So the whole shows kind of a weird thing to watch.
Um,
yeah,
might as well be her.
She looks like the cousin of that woman who had the slave themed wedding,
who used to do the cooking show and on the fucking food network whenever fucking
name is.
Um,
Jesus,
you guys think I'm in a bad move?
Watch that person show always with a scowl on their face.
She looks like that fucking monster.
And uh,
the fuck is it?
The uh,
bugs bunny,
you know,
monsters have such interesting life.
So whatever used to say,
uh,
when bugs bunny was doing the things here,
that no armed fucking monster,
right?
Um,
anyways,
sorry.
This is all jetlag fucking horse shit.
Uh,
okay.
The fuck am I talking about here?
Yeah.
I,
anytime I see somebody just completely fuck their life up on some level human
being,
the human being,
I just,
I just feel bad.
Like,
Oh God,
what did you do?
You know,
I don't condone it and think they should and I definitely think they should be
punished.
I don't know why.
I always look at that like go get that fucking Bernie Madoff guy.
I just can't imagine.
Just say,
I guess I'm looking at it like the person actually has empathy for other people.
Maybe they don't.
I'm putting myself into that situation where I would be going like,
ah God,
every day everybody's smiling.
You're the greatest bill.
Thanks for making me all this money and I've got to be like,
thank you.
Not to say that I haven't been a piece of shit in my life.
Well maybe that's what it is because I'd been a piece of shit,
so I don't know.
Excuse me for fucking feeling bad for an actor who made it and then fuck the
whole thing up.
That has got to be the most bizarre way ever to try and get a raise,
but I still don't think that that's why he was doing it.
I think he had like some sort of victim fantasy or something like that.
I think it was more that,
I don't think that that's how you get a raise and if the,
and I'll see if he really thinks that that's the way it was.
The was a way to get a raise.
Like there was the whole fucking thing was so crazy.
I feel like there's something about him that he's not all there and now he just
make it fun as somebody that has some sort of mental issue.
I Dunno.
Or He's like the world's dumbest criminal.
Maybe that's what it is.
I don't know.
But you know what sir,
I will try to pull my head out of my ass and,
and,
and have your thoughts,
which is what everybody else thinks and that'll be an entertaining podcast.
Welcome to what everybody else thinks.
I'm your host Bill Burr,
uh,
the new green deal.
Sir,
did you get this mad that the first mammal went extinct due to,
well,
human induced global warming.
Did you have that level of passion for it?
Okay.
All right.
The new green deal.
Yo,
Billy planet poss
I'm into saving the environment and I've been abstaining from plastic bags and
straws and buying the new iPhone every year for most of my life.
But I'm starting to question the narrative of certain things.
Okay.
Uh,
you talked about AOC.
I don't know what that is.
The young Congress woman with big ambitions wasn't sure if you heard this,
but in the New York green deal,
she's posting,
there was a line item supporting those who are not able to work and those who
are not willing,
uh,
granted this isn't likely to happen.
I think it's insane to suggest that someone should get a check for sitting
around on their ass.
My question is,
if the US government decided to do this in civil war was pending,
would you leave the country or refuse to pay taxes?
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Dude,
that,
that you went fucking vertical on that last line.
I mean,
if the US government decided to do it,
what the fuck?
What could I do about it?
I mean,
I,
I guess I would,
I essentially worked for free.
MMM.
I Dunno,
but it's,
what's killing me is,
is we,
we have the money to not with all the money that we pay in taxes.
If we would get out of these fucking wars,
okay.
Which are going nowhere and if just bankrupted us and made a very few amount of
people in this country,
super fucking rich,
you wouldn't have to then in and like this person is now coming along and going
after people and she's not,
she's not going to be able to get all of those super rich people do not have
their money in this country.
I saw this fascinating thing,
I talked about this before,
how they,
they,
they get it out of the country,
you know their corporation,
he set up a phony corporation and at one of these fucking islands and all the
money goes there.
And then there were an employee of that corporation and then they set up another
corporation and a different Ireland,
different company.
And then that deck cooperation bills,
the first one and then there's another one in another country and that one bills
this one and they just keep moving all of the money throughout these islands.
All these key is is it's different countries.
So with each country,
the IRS,
I guess the amount of red tape they have to go through and at each stop,
the corporation,
air quote corporation pays off somebody locally.
So it does cost them money to do that,
but not nearly as much as what they would pay in the United States.
And then when it gets to like the seventh or eighth buck in place,
that corporation
then gives the person in the United States who doesn't want to pay taxes,
gives them a alone yeah.
Gives them the money back in the form of a loan,
which isn't taxable.
And then they just never pay it back.
And the,
and the corporation quote forgives the loan.
So the taxes that that person paid was paying off people in each one of those
countries before it came back.
MMM.
Which is very sophisticated and I don't know.
That's how they fuck it.
Do it now.
This woman is not going to get those people.
What she's going to do is get,
like I said,
standup comedians that are suddenly selling tickets.
She's got to get kids out of college that,
you know,
created movement watches or,
or started an APP.
She's going to basically be going after and taxing the shit out of what makes
this country great.
The fact that you can come from nothing and you,
you can get to that,
the absolute heights,
you know,
depending on how hard you work,
your idea and your luck,
anyone can make it.
Um,
she's going to be going after that and completely ignoring
these corporations that have bankrupted this fucking country.
Polluted the fucking drinking water.
Turned up our,
our,
our food supply into poison have made money,
millions and billions of dollars in pharmaceutical,
uh,
the pharmaceutical industry and,
and,
and with all these people overdosing and all these families that are ripped
apart,
then Jenny,
she's not gonna go after any of those fucking people.
She's just going to get someone like me who's just a fucking individual.
That's it.
You saw what happened when Trump tried to tip,
pull the troops out of Syria.
You saw how both fucking Democrats and Republicans were like,
whoa.
They were,
that's where their bread is buttered.
By keeping those corporations,
making all that money on that fucking war,
on those fucking wars.
And then when they're done,
they then get to go around and give speeches and that's how they wash their
fucking bribe money.
And you watched this woman for all these big ideas she has.
She's going to come out the other side.
She's going to be a multi,
multi,
multi fucking millionaire.
She's going to have a fucking book deal.
She's going to be on TV,
she's going to go on the talk show circuit and everybody's going to just sit
there and talk about what a fucking inspiration she is.
And um,
you know,
it's just,
it's all bullshit.
And then meanwhile,
you know,
anybody who fucking,
when I had the balls to go after a dream and sleep on a futon until they were
like 38 and started making some money is going to be paying 70% taxes.
I guess that that's,
that's the solution to it.
I don't know.
I,
it doesn't seem like,
you know,
I know a lot of fucking people that if you just gave him a check every month
would just sit on their fucking ass and play video games.
Um,
just because this changing technology,
you have to fucking join it.
Learn how to fucking fix a robot's ACL or some shit.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
I'm sure there's a bunch of mechanics out there right now.
If you're smart,
you're starting to learn how to fix a,
an electric vehicle rather than sticking with gas combustion engines.
Kind of trying to keep yourself ahead of the fucking game.
That's what you have to do.
You got to fucking adjust.
Right.
I don't think the solution is to turn around,
you know,
I,
if I was running shit to,
to take more than 50% income tax off of anybody,
regardless of whether how much money they're making should be fucking criminal.
There's no way the person who did the job should make less money then the person
taxing you.
Um,
I dunno.
That's just my,
my fucking opinion.
What the hell do I know?
I mentioned somewhat.
Tell me,
I needed to take my head out of my ass.
But I would imagine if we,
you know,
converted to fucking solar power and an electric cars and all of that,
we would take a massive,
massive bite out of the Middle East and all of those people that fund these
fucking terrorist groups and,
okay.
Two things.
They wouldn't have the money
okay.
To be any sort of a threat to us.
We wouldn't be fucking over there.
And eventually they would just go back to fighting each other the same way they
fucking did in eastern Europe.
When Russia pulled out,
they went right back to picking up their fights.
They were like,
where,
where are we?
And he went right back to fucking killing each other.
So I don't know.
I know I'm over simplifying all of this shit,
but,
um,
I would think because we're their biggest customer,
that if we pulled out of there,
that would massively hurt any sort of terrorist groups ability.
Okay.
To try and go after us,
you know,
I don't know the fuck do I know why do you guys ask me such deep questions?
You know,
I don't fucking read the paper.
Right.
Longtime Ozzy lady listener,
a good day bell,
longtime listener here from Melbourne,
Australia.
Who would love to hear your take on my situation?
All right,
well did you realize you have to listen to my bad Aussie Aussie accent there.
I'm in the second half of my twenties out here.
We call that your late twenties.
I work in a TV job.
I love,
I'm independent,
have great friends and enough hobbies slash personal interest to keep me busy
and entertained in everyday life.
I've been told I'm a catch.
Okay.
But it ain't all rainbows and sunshine.
Uh,
not only am I single,
but by my cynicism,
by my citizen has become so powerful that it's compromising my ability to date
or trust,
I think you want to say,
but my wife cynicism,
a bit of a background here.
Years Ago I was in a longterm relationship with ended in heartache for me and
since then I've been through a sequence of disappointing dating experiences,
which has left me more lonely and unlovable each time people have named me.
Good luck,
chuck,
because whenever I get involved with anybody,
they settled down with the next person.
They come across.
I fear him becoming an angry person.
Men seem to think I'm more of a good time then along that a long time or a good
answer for boredom.
Uh,
I also need seem to attract men in relationships or worst married.
MMM.
But how can I become less of a cynic?
The reality is that some people just don't end up finding someone.
Well,
not with that attitude.
Uh,
they go through life falling in love alone or not at all.
My mother has,
has been single for 10 years and doesn't intend on changing that.
Uh,
do you think some people are meant to be alone?
Was there ever a point in your life where you thought you'd end up alone,
cheers and go fuck yourself?
Absolutely.
I did.
And I went through the same shit that you're going through.
Okay.
Yeah.
And I had,
you know,
women I dated and then I fucked it up and then they'd go on the next guy.
They'd marry him.
Yeah.
I had that happen a couple of times.
MMM.
And then I dated,
you know,
thought went through a while.
I thought women were psychos.
And then I just realized that what I was doing was I kept going up to roughly
the same kind of person.
I kept fishing in the same poisoned pond,
if you will.
I think you just need to get a little therapy and become a little more positive.
And obviously if somebody is married and in a relationship you shouldn't.
Okay.
You know,
I think that should be one of your first fucking questions.
MMM.
And there has to be something that you're doing.
And I'm saying this as,
as,
uh,
as a way as a positive thing that if that's what you're attracting,
there has to be something that you're doing that that can only happen so many
times before you got to be figuring out what the fuck am I doing?
That's what I did was psycho women while I was just so like,
you know,
you look at chicks who psychos and then after a while,
once you date like the third,
fourth,
fifth one in a row,
you like,
alright,
what am I doing?
Oh,
I'm deliberately going after these people cause I'm afraid to commit.
And then when they break up with me,
there's no fucking heartache because they're out of their fucking mind.
Um,
so
I think some people were meant to be alone,
but it doesn't sound like you are.
If you are meant to be alone,
you would be way more okay with it than you are.
And this doesn't just seem like you're looking at the herd and it's making you
question yourself.
You sound like you want to find love.
So what I would do is take some of your TV money and I would get a good
therapist and I would do some work on yourself and uh,
start fishing in a different pond.
How about that?
Did I oversimplify what was going on?
I probably did.
MMM.
Anyways.
Anyway,
I'm just gonna keep saying anyways,
I think that's one of my charms that I don't,
I don't have command with my own language.
Um,
all right.
That is the,
uh,
that is the podcast.
Geez,
we got fucking deep on this one,
Huh?
Okay.
Passing of Steven Brody Stevens.
My hottest solves the fucking Middle East problem,
the audacity to be doing that.
And uh,
I don't know what else.
Look at it.
As Keith Robinson just texted me,
he's like,
ha ha.
Looks like Robert Kraft won't be going to the White House this year.
Oh yeah,
I guess so.
Go cry with his six fucking trophies.
Okay.
Not to mention,
I don't know.
I don't,
I've never had this experience before that my teams,
the team that wins everything.
It was,
it always this fucking petty.
That's all they do is just come up with petty shit.
Huh?
I guess he won't be fucking dud.
That's like,
okay.
Yeah,
I guess we'll just have to fucking cry on Mark Trophies and move on.
It'd be they're not taking the team away.
Who gives a shit?
And I don't like that.
It's fucking,
it's Donald Trump.
He was probably,
he was probably the driver and the getaway car from the rub and tug.
Did you grab them by the pussies?
Um,
anyways.
All right.
Anyway,
that is the,
uh,
that is the podcast.
Uh,
congratulations to everybody out there.
That one,
the shiny things,
my condolences for those who didn't.
Um,
I hope people who watch movies and were offended by them could somehow move past
it and find a reason to get up in the morning tomorrow.
MMM.
People would sort of,
it's a fucking award show.
I mean,
there
don't,
don't they fuck it up in your business to top sales men.
And everybody's sitting is fucking God Brown.
Noser he's banging the fucking boss.
His daughter was getting married to her.
That's why he fucking wanting,
you know,
isn't there always that shit?
There's always gonna be that shit.
You know,
quit your fucking crying.
It's not what's,
what a fucking great country.
This is,
you know,
it's such a great country.
People complain about the movies.
I didn't like the way it made people with red shirts.
Look,
Ooh.
Yeah.
He wanted his fucking polar bears.
Fucking drowning.
Um,
add another flat screen to you.
Fucking TV.
See Your fucking TV room c can fucking watch the Oscars and cry about it.
Um,
all right,
I'm off my fucking soapbox.
Uh,
here we go.
I'm in the bubble.
Everybody.
I am in the bubble of this time.
Next week was going to be Monday.
I'm gonna be doing my first taping and then the next day I'll do my next taping
and then now we will be putting this hour and 30 minutes to fucking bed.
Uh,
I can't wait.
I'm very excited.
I miss my daughter and wife terribly and I'm,
I'm really gonna take it easy this year.
I really am.
I'm talking to my agent.
I'm going to be the California kid.
I'm doing gigs out in fucking Cali.
I'm just gonna stay in the southwest.
I'm going to fluff.
I can't fly southwest of the Gig in under 50 minutes.
I'm not fucking doing it and I'm just going to fucking chill.
I got an acting Gig this summer.
Then I'll bring in my wife and kid along too.
And uh,
I'm just going to slip some life and let this thing come together.
Uh,
oh my God,
my wife sent me this video of my kids singing the abcs and I do this thing.
I don't know if I,
I probably already told you the shit.
So fucking jet lag.
But I do this thing the way I sing,
the abcs,
I go a,
B,
c,
d e F,
g,
H,
I,
J,
k l m n o,
p Gig.
You know,
bouncing up and down.
She just laughs and all that stuff.
So now she can do the abcs and she throws the haze in there.
She's like [inaudible],
Hey t u v,
hey,
it's the cutest fucking thing over.
And it's all that matters in life.
And then you fucking put on the TV and you watch delts fucking whining because
they didn't get the star on their forehead.
Who gives a fuck?
You're making movies,
you're a millionaire,
you're bang and beautiful women.
You know,
what the fuck else do you need?
I wanted the shiny thing.
I like the flag.
We Academy
fucking half the people in the world trying to just get a fucking sandwich.
Boohoo I didn't get a trophy.
I will never get,
I will never fucking understand that.
But then again,
I do watch sports and I get excited that my team wins trophies and I'm about
ready to fucking trash.
Keith Robinson and his,
sorry ass fucking cowboys who the Patriots just passed for more super bowl
titles.
Um,
we've one more super bowl titles.
What am I going to say?
Damn.
We one more super bowl titles and the last two decades than the cowboys have one
in their entire fucking history.
Tom Brady has more rings than all the Dallas Cowboy quarterbacks combined.
Oh,
I'll do,
I have some ammo and I have to take advantage of it now.
Cause I know when Tom Leaves and bill Belicheck retires,
you know,
I have faith in like the fucking,
but I also have wait Robert Craft,
right?
Simply trying to buy a strip mall and checking up the stores.
That fucking guy,
arguably the greatest owner of all time.
When you look at his coaching hires,
he's hired three coaches.
Bill Parcells a fucking,
what's his name there?
Woo.
It just totally forgot his fucking name.
Pete Carroll.
Bill Belicheck three for fucking three hall of famers.
That's two Superbowl,
three Superbowl,
nine super bowls amongst all of them.
Amazing.
All right,
that's it.
That's the podcast.
Go fuck yourselves.
And I will talk to you.
Uh,
I'll check in on you in a couple of days.
I don't know where I'm going to be,
but I got Liverpool the next couple of,
uh,
the next couple of nights and,
very excited to be here.
I've never been here,
and as much as I was making fun of all that Beetle Shit,
I'm definitely gonna go look at it.
You know,
I got it.
I'm not going to go to the pub where they fucking start is,
of course,
I'm going to go right now,
I'm going to,
you know,
and know like,
I don't think I'm going to go to all their fucking houses.
Rural is his way.
Ringo was sleeping.
Was it?
How the fuck do I know that?
All right,
I'll see you.